>> Larry: TONIGHTLY, BOBBY
JINDAL GETS A BIG ENDORSEMENT
FROM...
NAH, I'M JUST KIDDING.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE CELEBRATING HISTORY!
IT'S  BIG GAY MONDAY!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
COME ON OUT!
YEAH!
THAT'S RIGHT, EVERYBODY!
ON FRIDAY, HISTORY WAS MADE WHEN
THE SUPREME COURT LEGALIZED
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE NATIONWIDE.
SING IT, BOYS!
(CHORUS SINGING)
♪ ALL 50 STATES, START SETTING
SOME DATES ♪
SOME DATES ♪♪
>> Larry: FINALLY, EQUAL
RIGHTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
(CHORUS SINGING)
♪ IT'S ABOUT (BLEEP) TIME WE'RE
TREATED LIKE EQUALS ♪
TREATED LIKE EQUALS ♪♪
>> Larry: SO LET'S GET THIS
PARTY STARTED.
THIS IS THE "THE NIGHTLY SHOW"!
LET'S DO THIS!
(CHORUS SINGING)
♪ THIS IS "THE NIGHTLY SHOW" ♪
♪ THIS IS "THE NIGHTLY SHOW" ♪♪
Captioning sponsored by
COMEDY CENTRAL
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: LET'S DO THIS!
♪♪
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: WELCOME TO THE "THE
NIGHTLY SHOW."
(AUDIENCE CHANTING LARRY)
>> Larry: THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
WELCOME TO "THE NIGHTLY SHOW"!
LOOK AT THE SET!
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL!
RAINBOW FLAVOR GOING ON!
I'M LARRY WILMORE.
TONIGHT, IN HONOR OF THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION TO LEGALIZE
MARRIAGE FOR EVERYONE, WELCOME
TO LARRY WILMORE'S 2015 YAAAASSS
KWEEN YAAAASSS
MARRIAGE-TRAVAGANZAAAA A
SLIPPERY SLOPE TO HAPPINAAAASS!
ROLL IT!
♪ LARRY WILMORE'S 2015 YAAAASSS
KWEEN YAAAASSS
MARRIAGE-TRAVAGANZAAAA:  A
SLIPPERY SLOPE TO
HAPPINAAAASS ♪♪
>> Larry: YES!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WHOO!
NICE!
GIVE IT UP FOR THE NEW YORK CITY
GAYMEN'S CHORUS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THIS IS BIG GAY MONDAY TO
CELEBRATE WHAT HAPPENED FRIDAY.
REPORTERS WERE ON THE SUPREME
COURT'S STEPS WAITING FOR THEIR
PRODUCERS TO BRING THEM THE GAY
MARRIAGE RULING.
AH, BUT WHAT NETWORK WOULD HAVE
THE STORY FIRST?
WOULD IT BE AMERICA'S NEWS ROOM,
FOX NEWS?
LET'S SEE.
>> WE HAVE AN OPINION COMING!
WE HAVE THE DECISION.
WE HAVE THE DECISION COMING.
IT'S COMING!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> JASON!
JASON!
>> Larry: JASON!
WHERE THE (BLEEP) IS JASON!
SORRY FOX NEWS, MAYBE JASON RAN
OFF TO MARRY HIS LONGTIME
PARTNER.
(LAUGHTER)
OR MAYBE HE'S SEEKING ASYLUM
FROM FOX NEWS?
WHO KNOWS!
ALL I KNOW IS THAT JASON'S NOT
HERE!
JASON!
(LAUGHTER)
ANYWAY, THE SUPREME COURT RULED
5-4 IN FAVOR OF GAY MARRIAGE.
OBAMA IMMEDIATELY GOT ON THE
PHONE TO CONGRATULATE THE LEAD
PLAINTIFF IN THE DECISION, JIM
OBERGEFELL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
TAKE CARE.
>> THANKS FOR THE CALL,
MR. PRESIDENT.
>> BYE-BYE.
>> BYE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS BYE-BYE.
>> Larry: THE PRESIDENT SAYS
BYE-BYE.
C'MON, WOLFMAN, YOU DON'T NEED
TO REPORT THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
NOT EVERYTHING THE PRESIDENT
SAYS REQUIRES THE FULL POWERS OF
THE SITUATION ROOM.
ANYWAY, OBAMA WASN'T DONE
SPREADING THE GAY MARRIAGE LOVE.
FRIDAY NIGHT, OBAMA'S WHITE
HOUSE WAS BATHED IN RAINBOW
LIGHTS.
IN FACT, EVERYBODY WAS IN THE
RAINBOW SPIRIT.
NIAGARA FALLS WAS LIT UP.
SO WAS THE EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING.
EVEN DICK CHENEY HAD RAINBOW
LIGHTS AT HIS HOUSE.
WE'RE NOT MAKING THAT UP!
DICK CHENEY GOT ON BOARD, MAN.
(LAUGHTER)
OF COURSE, EVERYBODY WASN'T
HAPPY ABOUT THE DECISION.
BUT TODAY IS TOO MOMENTOUS A DAY
TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME FOCUSING
ON THE HATERS.
SO HERE'S A SHORT LOOK AT THE
HATIN' SPONSORED BY HATER-ADE'S
CUT-RATE COMPETITOR,
POWER-HATER-ADE.
WHEN YOU NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AT ATTACKING OTHER PEOPLE'S
SUCCESS, TRY POWER-HATER-ADE.
IT'S BLUE, AND IT'S A LITTLE
CHEAPER THAN HATER-ADE.
MM-MMM...
SALTY.
-- LET'S START IN LOUISIANA
GOVERNOR AND PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE BOBBY JINDAL
SAID THAT "NO EARTHLY
COURT CAN ALTER THE DEFINITION
OF MARRIAGE."
NO EARTHLY COURT?
IS THERE SOME KIND OF
INTERGALACTIC COURT?
YOU DO NOT WANT TO TAKE THINGS
TO SPACE COURT, BOBBY JINDAL.
THEY ARE ASSHOLES IN SPACE
COURT.
THEY CAN READ YOUR MIND.
(ALIEN VOICE... )
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU, BOBBY
JINDAL.
YOU JUST WANT A SHOW ON FOX
NEWS.
CASE DISMISSED.
GET MARRIED, EVERYBODY.
HA HA HA.
HA HA.
(APPLAUSE)
SPACE COURT, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TED CRUZ
CRUZ'D OVER TO THE "TODAY" SHOW
TODAY AND PUT IT IN CRUZ
CONTROL!
>> ONE OF THE THINGS JUSTICE
SCALIA TALKS ABOUT, YOU'VE GOT
NINE LAWYERS, THEY'RE ALL FROM
HARVARD OR YALE, THERE ARE NO
PROTESTANTS ON THE COURT, THERE
ARE NO EVANGELICALS ON THE
COURT.
>> Larry: THERE ARE NO MUSLIMS
ON THE COURT.
NO BUDDHISTS.
NO KLINGONS OR ROMULANS.
ONCE AGAIN, WE GOTTA GO TO SPACE
COURT TO FIND REAL COURT
DIVERSITY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND WHAT WOULD A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVE BLOVIATING  BE
WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP?
THAT'S RIGHT.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
TRUMP SAT DOWN FOR (TRUMP VOICE)
THE CLASSIEST, MOST INCREDIBLE
INTERVIEW EVER (END TRUMP VOICE)
WITH CNN'S JAKE TAPPER THIS
WEEKEND.
HEAR'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
TOPIC VEERED TO GAY MARRIAGE.
>> I'M TRADITIONAL MARRIAGE.
IT'S CHANGING RAPIDLY.
>> BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY TO A
LESBIAN WHO'S MARRIED OR A GAY
MAN WHO'S MARRIED WHO SAYS,
DONALD TRUMP, WHAT'S TRADITIONAL
ABOUT BEING MARRIED THREE TIMES?
>> WELL, WELL, THEY HAVE A GOOD
POINT.
>> Larry: THEY HAVE AN
EXCELLENT (BLEEP)ING POINT!
OH!
JAKE TAPPER!
YOU JUST TAPPER-ED THAT ASS!
THAT'S MY BOY!
AND FINALLY, JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS.
HE'S NOT A REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE,
BUT I DO WISH HE WOULD RUN...
INTO AN OPEN PIT.
SORRY, I COULDN'T STOP MYSELF.
HE CHOSE TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUE
OF DIGNITY.
AND, OF COURSE, HE USED THE
OBVIOUS SLAVE ANALOGY.
ACCORDING TO THOMAS, "SLAVES DID
NOT LOSE THEIR DIGNITY (ANY MORE
THAN THEY LOST THEIR HUMANITY)
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT ALLOWED
THEM TO BE ENSLAVED."
DO YOU EVEN KNOW WHAT SLAVERY
IS?
SLAVERY IS THE COMPLETE
STRIPPING OF HUMANITY AND
DIGNITY.
THAT'S THE POINT OF SLAVERY.
AND WHEN DO YOU THINK SLAVES
WERE WHIPPED?
WHENEVER THEY DARED TO TRY TO
SHOW ANY HUMANITY OR DIGNITY.
CLARENCE, PLEASE APPROACH THE
BENCH AND THEN JUMP OFF OF IT
INTO THAT SAME AFOREMENTIONED
PIT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
LOOK, THAT'S WHAT THE WHOLE GAY
MARRIAGE FIGHT HAS BEEN ALL
ABOUT.
NOT ABOUT CHANGING THE
DEFINITIONS OR UPSETTING
INSTITUTIONS.
THE FIGHT HAS SIMPLY BEEN ABOUT
HUMANITY AND DIGNITY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.